Salut à tous ! Je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
On nous bassine à longueur d'année avec les changements climatiques
Franchement, deux degrés, ça casse pas trois pattes à un canard
Négatif !
Parce que, deux degrés, sur la planète entière, ça va être une situation catastrophique
La fonte des glaces va faire disparaître des îles et des côtes entières
- ça va pas ? Je fais pas comme il faut ?
- Noon, non non non, c'est... c'est bien de s'inspirer de ce qu'il se fait sur internet, c'est pas une mauvaise idée
- Si si, c'est clairement une mauvaise idée
- Et puis surtout Dave l'a déjà fait
- Bon, Nicolas a fait appel à nous pour qu'on trouve quelque chose d'original pour sensibiliser internet
C'est pas pour faire un lipdub.
-En fait je pense que ce qu'il manque c'est quelque chose de visuellement puissant vous voyez, un truc badass quoi.
-"Badass" ?
-Ouais, Badass
C'est "méchant" "cul"
Dans un monde où l'inconscience de l'homme a totalement déséquilibré le climat.
Où les catastrophes naturelles sont de plus en plus fréquentes.
Un homme, seul, décide de se lever contre tous pour leur foutre une bonne grosse raclée.
Son nom : Nicolas YOLO ! Ahahahahah
Hum... Peut-être euh... Vous m'avez pas dit les ampoules là  :
C'est des ampoules basses consommations au moins on est sûrs de ça ?
Non parce que c'est vachement important pour moi !
- (chuchote) C'était pas Hulot à la base ?
Comme un hublot mais sans le b ?
Mouais mais j'ai un peu peur qu'on le prenne pas au sérieux quand même
- Pour moi c'est pas le bon message hein, si on peut essayer d'être un peu moins pessimiste tu vois
- Il a raison, il faut qu'on trouve quelque chose de plus simple, une idée réaliste que n'importe qui peut comprendre.
-Gaël !
-Quoi ?
- Tu veux tirer sur mon doigt pour voir comment ça fait ?
-Ok !
-Bapt !
-Oooh mais ça marche pas c'est bizarre !
- Mais, c'est comme si y avait plus rien dans mon c...
-Il peut plus péter !
-Parce que "prout", c'est du méthane et le méthane c'est un gaz à effet de serre vous voyez ?
Donc en fait ...
-Oui, ça j'avais compris
-Ok ok
-Mais je pense que si on veut agir plus efficacement pour réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de serre,
-Maintenant c'est de la responsabilité des politiques.
-Et c'est pour ça qu'on est là !
Il faut les secouer, il faut qu'on trouve une idée qui mobilise un maximum de personnes et qui soit partagé dans le monde entier !
-J'ai !
-Et qui délivre un message clair, quitte à frapper du poing sur la table
-C'est maintenant, messieurs les dirigeants qu'il faut agir. Demain ça sera trop tard.
-De toute façon c'est trop tard déjà
-Stotototop ! Stop Nico ! Stop !
Tu sais pas y faire, laisse-moi laisse-moi laisse-moi laisse-moi faire
Salut bande de salopes des gouvernements du monde !
Vous voyez ça ? C'est une putain de planète !
Alors vous vous êtes là : "Oui euh c'est mon pétrole euh, moi je veux mon pétrole"
BORDEL ! Si vous vous mettez pas d'accord, eh bah voilà ce qui va se putain de passer !
Batte ! Meeerde ! La planète, elle a bobo !
-Trop violent...Faut, faudrait qu'on parte sur un truc plus doux !
-Oui, moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on délivre un message de paix
-Ouais !
-Gaël !
-Quoi ?
-Non !
-Ah bon ?
-Donc on a toujours pas parlé de la pétition.
-Pour ça j'ai ma petite idée.
-Salut à tous c'est Kayane ! Aujourd'hui on va tester un tout nouveau personnage dans Street Fighter
Captain Cop21 et je suis avec son créateur, Nicolas Hulot.
-Salut !
-Alors explique-moi les coups spéciaux de ce nouveau personnage !
-C'est simple : avant, arrière plus R2, et là il sort une pétition.
-Euh, tu veux dire des munitions ?
-Non... Une pétition ! Je crois que t'as pas conscience que quand des milliers de personnes signent une pétition c'est hyper puissant mon truc
-Ok...Bon... Je viens de gagner !
-Ah ouais d'accord ..!
-On peux faire une pause ?
-Enfin, peut-être tout simplement je sais pas délivrer un message sobre et efficace, à l'américaine non ?
-Pffff Ahahahaha ! It's "akward" ! Ahahah
-Non non mais, t'es sympa hein du coup mais.. Chacun son métier, hein ?
-Attendez, je vois : tous les guests  d'internet qui débarquent comme ça et qui font un message "émouvant" Ahahah !
-Et du piano ! Ahahah
-Attends, attends, deux secondes : regardez
-Bonjour. Bienvenue dans un message sobre, et efficace, à l'Américaine.
Pour l'occasion d'ailleurs j'ai mis une moustache et un béret à la française.
Voilà ça fait 20 ans qu'on entend
-Qu'il est temps de prendre soin de notre planète et de l'environnement.
-Alors vous vous demandez sûrement : "d'accord, mais quoi faire ?"
-Il faut que je ferme le robinet pendant que je me brosse les dents ?
-Que je trie bien mes déchets ?
-Que je mange bio ?
-Ouais c'est vrai faut faire tout ça mais... Mais c'est pas de ça qu'on vous parle aujourd'hui.
-Il y a un rendez-vous historique en décembre, à Paris : la Cop21.
-Ce nom, il est vraiment nul, mais bon
-Tous les chefs d'Etats du monde vont se réunir pour prendre des décisions sur le climat.
-C'est une occasion en or pour leur rappeler
-Qui les a élu, et pourquoi ils sont à ce poste.
-De quoi ont-ils le plus peur ? De ne pas se faire réélire.
-Comment faire pression ?
-En signant la pétition
-*siffle* On signe.
-Plus nous serons nombreux
-Plus nos chefs d'Etats seront obligés de faire bouger les choses.
-Alors évidemment certains diront : "ce n'est pas mon combat" ou
-"moi je signe jamais les pétitions"
-Franchement c'est un principe de merde si t'as ça dans ta vie "moi je signe jamais les pétitions"
-Ou alors je ne sais pas trop quoi penser de ce "Nicolas Hulot"
-Là n'est pas la question.
-L'enjeu est d'une importance capitale.
-Et bien au-dessus des opinions politiques
-Des affinités pour telles ou telles personnes ou des opinions personnelles.
-L'enjeu est d'enfin s'unir, pour dire d'une seule voix :
-"C'est votre dernière chance de nous prouver qu'on ne vous a pas élus pour rien !"
-Ce n'est plus l'avenir qui se décide, c'est le présent.
-Nous pouvons reprendre notre destin en main.
-N'ayons pas peur, osons !
-Faites entendre votre voix
-Chaque signature compte
-Chaque voix compte
-Ok les gars : idée, pour la vidéo là.
Un mec, il vient du futur, il remonte le temps. Avec quoi ? Une machine
Pour remonter le temps. Vous suivez ? Ok
Le gars il remonte le temps il dit : "Signez la pétition sinon, voici ce qu'il va arriver"
Et la succession d'images hyper cut hyper rapide.
-François ?
-Oui ?
-Il s'est barré Nicolas Hulot. C'est fini là.
-Je vais la garder pour moi, cette idée ! Oui ! Et vous l'aurez bien dans le cul !